[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
today we have jason cheney in the back
hey
thank you dude i feel so hyped up you
guys did the thing and drama yeah yeah i
feel really welcome yeah i saw your arms
come up dude are you a comedian or
you're a lifter bro he's a power he look
out he's a guy
this guy's jack tried so hard
[ __ ] boys and girls you must be
really special man really yeah
oh my god anybody who's got [ __ ]
biceps and chin i'm ready [ __ ] jason
cheney everybody
[Music]
you look at the guy in little tokyo
oh arthur
dude
you feel even better now i do
and it was such a short set too you
pulled it out just for that i really
appreciate it one more thing
one more thing before we start with
jason cheney can we just give a round of
applause for anthony lee's haircut
it's beautiful it looks great thank you
thank you this guy's even higher level
silk city now bro
thank you for that back to jason
wait we do stand up comedy and you lift
yeah i try to um yeah i do i i don't
lift but i do kettlebells recently and i
do push-ups but i have kettlebells and
push-ups so you got all that [ __ ] it's
genetics
a lot of genetics well you know are you
i'm stronger than you a thousand percent
i know i could [ __ ] live more than
you but you look better than me thank
you man that's all that matters to me i
just gotta look good so everyone in your
family tree is just like mad buff and
hilarious all of them like your mom's
bluff
my dad is fat but my mom
it's on your mom's side said yeah lucky
dad
yeah what is it like
because i uh to be a stand-up comedian
but also good looking because i heard
that they don't like that [ __ ] no and it
makes it much harder to be a guy because
they're ugly [ __ ] and
no no no but um
don't be modest you can't call people
ugly [ __ ] and then backtrack right a
lot of comics are ugly dude that's
[ __ ] true
funny though there's a lot of guys
i have to say this but honestly i've
been real this is really recent i i
never thought that i was decent looking
until recently until why
you were doing shorts and then you're
like you're giving me a [ __ ] for why
and then you're like getting all these
groupies and you're like why middle of
the blow jobs when he [ __ ] had that
revelation i must be decent looking
what gave you the thought that like oh
corey i'm good looking is it good she
came out
did you know that a lot of asian kids
they're like they place their own value
on whatever [ __ ] media is right
that's true [ __ ] after saying she came
out everybody was like i'm slaying i
have hope in this world i started
wearing letterman jackets what does that
have to do i thought you were going to
go somewhere else with that yeah that
was fire
he's ugly that's [ __ ] up anthony the
fact that you thought that so quickly
that movie just reinforces the idea that
you need to know a shitload of martial
arts
yeah what kind of kung fu do you know
jason chan all of them
no no no no what gave you that thought
like oh cool i'm not ugly
hey cool
i i think uh
what i i still i still think about it
sometimes but
i think because of social media because
before i i wasn't a social media guy and
recently i started to do it and then um
and then people will be like hey
do i mean
hey here's my boobies
okay okay okay oh so people are sending
you pics yeah some of them here's my
book jason those are spam by the way i
know but i'm married it tells us that
yeah yeah
they're like it's 50 an hour and i was
like what i thought i thought you were a
real person no but
with like just mutual friends and stuff
and they'll give me compliments but i
would never
like i never
was around
like i don't really hang out i don't
really have friends who are women
because i'm married for a while now
how long how long have you been
why are you laughing at me
why is that not what are you laughing at
it's just the way you say it it just it
just makes us laugh it's also because i
really i'm really focused in my career
because like you got time for [ __ ] is
what he's saying no but i never i was
never i never i was never confident
enough to
yeah i was never accommodated but now
that you get so many boobies
do you ever do you ever reevaluate your
marriage like i should have upgraded way
higher you're like i gotta i gotta
refinance
refinance refinance your marriage yeah
you ever refinance your marriage of
course not oh really what
[Laughter]
no no um but i feel like so some
sometimes people would ask us
ask us when i say us i mean me um that
when are you when did you know that
you're
you it's your wife is the one but i
don't think that's a thing like there
isn't a moment that i'm like oh man
she's
the one so you can have many ones
she's still under review really she's
still an escrow that's what happened
how long have you been married for for
like five years but we've been together
for like 15 years we known each other we
broke up several times but because of oh
it's on and off type thing it wasn't
like that the way you said it but
how is it that what is it like it's
really got a dimmer switch yeah
if you had this car of a marriage that
didn't start so many times how did you
know i'm gonna keep this car forever
yeah
cause you guys work through it right
yeah yeah we broke up and it came back
together several times but not on and
off
no not like that not the way you said it
you make it too real
you guys both say you don't want to make
it too real dude
you give me like that yeah
it's not like yeah don't say that dude
it was like it was kind of on and kind
of off but don't say it like that
not like that
15 years is a long time
do you have him beat who nah he got me
beat we've only been together for 12
years and we've only been married for
once he married so i'm a [ __ ] loser
it's always a competition everybody's
love relationship is a conversation but
when did you know you i feel like you
have to constantly work on it is it 100
it's more of like as you go through
things like he's still finding out he's
still he's kind of like this right now
my wife is still finding out she's like
yo i don't know but this gun is a good
deal anymore that's what she's saying
yeah my conversation last night my
journey was like uh i knew i i remember
the exact moment where i knew she was
the one because my parents were really
shitty
and then i remember on one of our first
dates she brought out her nephews and
nieces there's three of them
and we were at focus plaza over there i
thought we were doing it with playing
boba and i remember the exact moment
where she was like how she handled each
one of those kids was really fair got
everyone above and sat him down and i'm
like that's the mother of my child in
the future
but after we got together she became a
[ __ ] dirty [ __ ]
and so it's one of those where to get
sold on the [ __ ] sweepstakes right
and then it goes
and then you enter to win this car now
and then now you gotta work on it
[ __ ] hard to [ __ ] break up and all
this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] to get on and
now he just has a time share
with seven other people dude but but
that doesn't just because
she
is a um not a clean
pull
say it doesn't
that doesn't mean she's not the best
mother though
the best partner is the thing so that's
why i try to convince him that you're a
great mother not a good wife i can still
go looking for life yeah that's okay
really
okay age this is how we rock on this
side of the table
mexican we're a bunch of outfits over
here brother trying to give all women a
chance here this is a little
uncomfortable
you guys don't last the whole day
usually
during your like the problems that you
would have with marriage did any of that
ever have anything to do with your uh
chosen profession as a comedian um
that's a really good question
that's a really good question man
i'm not gonna answer
that's such a good question i'm gonna
shut the [ __ ] up big question bro
okay can you repeat i think we got the
answer can you repeat that i love the
way you said that
that's what people need to think they
ask you again
can you repeat that again
[Laughter]
no really i think he needs it yeah i
think he needs it oh really yeah yeah
yeah
because uh the pause was
let's hear joe try it joe can you try
that question again uh jose i was
thinking about potatoes
basically did you and your wife ever
fight like
gold red potatoes rusty potatoes
dutch that's yellows he's still gaining
his breath back from that piano
did you and your wife ever fight about
anything comedy related
wait do you still uh
do you still like the so oh so sorry i
need more time to think
do i
uh so
but you check out a lot no
joe do you check out
i'm there and i'm here occasionally i
heard you guys but i'm just enjoying the
ride
that's the best answer he's an astral
projector
sometimes i'm in africa sometimes i'm in
asia i haven't been traveling so you
know
that's the best thing is to have mental
vacations
what i call it because it's like it's a
good time yeah because guys like walter
mitty or whatever oh yeah sometimes
sometimes do we guys fight yeah she's
like we're supposed to go on a date and
you're like i got a [ __ ] show to do
at the laugh factory like has she ever
has the source of the fight ever been
your career career as a comedian yeah
where she's like if you didn't if you
hadn't been a comedian this [ __ ] would
have never happened why couldn't you
like make fun of her in your like bits
yeah like in yourself i don't want you
to laugh at me like that
with so many uh messages
yes yeah and also i would answer
to some of them
you're a politician bro
you are the worst politician just
explaining what i'm going to answer what
i'm not
he likes
you're good right good remember us when
you're in office bro was she never like
you should have been an engineer no i
honestly she's so patient because she's
a kindergarten teacher and
she's so patient with me and
she's uh in the beginning there was some
like fights and stuff but uh she's so
understanding and she knows that
um
also if i can't make this a successful
career is gonna be
her too is the thing because i'm like if
i do
if i'm very successful
uh financially i don't because i just
want to do stand-up so it's gonna be
yours anyways and but that's a great
question but but because but of course i
wanna i spend so much time in my career
that i don't really see her and also we
have different schedules because i'll
either be on the road when i this is too
serious somebody make a joke no no no
that's what you got to talk about
this is great people like it this is how
you become mayor so yeah yeah yeah i
didn't know i didn't know you were uh
you only did stand up like that's all
that's the only thing you're on the road
and then you're like a traditional
strand stand-up dude that just [ __ ]
hits the road and just hits club sit-ups
too apparently
sit-ups and stand-ups
yeah so you're mostly on the road yeah
for the longest time but now um because
of social
social media you could do it on the road
too but a lot of people is like hey you
got to be in la and take some chances
and take a risk even though if you're
not making money um you know maybe you
could do a tv something yeah like get an
opportunity and um so i wanted a classic
la dream yeah and then where are you
originally from taiwan but i
yeah i came here when i was 13 13. would
you be offended if right when you said
taiwan i went ah china
he just walks out
no yes he's like i look way different
okay
he has really good bits about china and
taiwan so i just do you have bits about
taiwan china
yeah but the thing i'm half chinese are
you really yeah how do you feel why did
you say it like that
why do you keep hearing things like that
[Laughter]
he just says everything's sexy sorry
there's a lot of too much taiwanese here
today yeah too much time inside of the
room you're you're you're happy i'm a
halfer yeah yeah wait that's too much
he's more like singaporean though what's
the limit
you know you know how like singaporeans
different
it's like the wakanda of asia you know
what i mean they just like they
understand things differently
it's the silicon valley of southeast
asia the wakanda very eco-friendly
eco-friendly echo or eco which one is it
you're talking about you should be both
it's like if north korea and wakanda had
a baby
because underneath it's like north korea
i like the north korea part yeah that's
my favorite part about singapore because
if you chew gum they [ __ ] you up they
[ __ ] you up they can you dude
that's a north korean tradition [ __ ] up
people who chew gum
but they're also like las vegas because
you could [ __ ] a hooker anywhere yeah
you could go to the mall there's a hook
yeah there's zing reporters hook is
hooker friendly yeah they're hot
singapore is hooker friendly my mom last
time we're in singapore we stayed in
this place that has a lot of you know
prostitutes that live there and um or
sex workers or whatever you call them
and she was like hey you guys let's go
on a night on the town and she took us
around and she's like this is where all
the sex workers are and this is where
all the australian dudes come
and take out money from the atm and
purchase the women she showed them the
atm specifically she was like this is
the atm it was like she it was late
night and she was like hey what else are
we gonna do let's go for a nice walk and
then she showed us all around singapore
that's a nice one that's my mom
how much is it i don't know i didn't ask
okay um but next time i'm there i'll
inquire for probably thank you it's
crazy how like uh what's acceptable and
unacceptable in different countries
because i was watching this video with
tim and his dad
and his dad was saying like he was like
asking his dad when he loses lose his
virginity and i think he said like 15 or
16. and then tim's like what the [ __ ] is
that young for your generation and goes
no it's weird if you haven't there's
hookers everywhere
so if you haven't lost your virginity
your friends will take you to go yeah
that's tight i was like there's a tie
that's tight bro honestly like just rip
the band-aid off you
you lose your virginity to a hooker
that's not to a professional to a
professional yeah
yeah cause like when you
because then when you want to go to
somebody that you care about look them
in the eye you you want to be a little
more experienced you know without them
knowing yeah you don't want to be a
creep you know you want to be a weirdo
you want to wear them out like yeah i
had sex with hooker you just want to be
like is it my first time yeah but like
can i work around this moment maybe yeah
that's really true two different ways to
think about it i guess yeah two
different that's what i heard from my
friends for me though it's just all love
because i never did anything wrong yeah
nina why you gotta make it so real
like i make it so real you know you
don't
no no no because you seem like you're
writing a open letter so i'll just
always gotta throw in the [ __ ]
pronouns when you said nina i looked
around like she was in the room for some
reason i don't know who's he was citing
an open letter hey back to
jason over here just focus so taiwan huh
yeah
how do you feel about taiwan because i'm
gonna ask a kind of personal question
okay um because you got like that asian
don't raise them and kind of like
are you a lot older than you
look how old are you yeah it's [ __ ]
same age as ip yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're donny yet
like you can honestly be anywhere from
like 26 to like 38. that's true that's
very realistically yeah plus you're in
good health and fitness so he's probably
even older yeah 26 to 48 38. oh don't
get mad at me
he's like [ __ ] potatoes
you could do i feel like if you shave
your um and make this about you again
um but yeah i feel like most asians
could do that so so are you not going to
reveal it that's fine
i don't care
i'm 31.
politicians that was your layup just to
say your age you weirdo just say you're
yeah my age 31. i i don't care about
that wait don't make it too real
like tell me what he looks like okay
yeah but
what he looks like his age you want the
real thing
just say the number dude why are you
getting
this is frustrating i'm sorry you guys
i [ __ ] up now nick gets a taste of his
own medicine no but how old are you
now i don't believe you're 31. because
you deflected so much i think you're a
liar now yeah
good for you though 31 man what did you
look like give him the truth okay like
30
[Laughter]
seconds thirty twenty thirty two
that's a year dude thirty thirty three
three thirty seven thirty seven dude you
could [ __ ] thirty five he [ __ ]
looks 21 just saying 35 do you think
he's four years older than you are like
[ __ ] 15 dude stop guessing
stop guessing 32 okay i'm 29 no you're
not all right i'm 38.
are you 29 yeah
okay it's because you're very
experienced in what dude not in love
making i'll tell you that all right i
don't know why it happened yeah dude
jason jason how old do you think this is
how do you think how do you think mark
is how do you think he looks it's around
this
around the same like 30
30 20
30 10 30
asians rule the world
yeah how do you think how do you think
bart is like 30 uh just one number just
one number and just stick with it all
right and that's what you stick with
jesse company
all right i'll be confident right now
36 36 wow that's good how about right do
right you're right
i feel like ryan has a
younger face but
i think you're older oh
i feel like you guys are all just saying
the number dude all right 39 man
30 no 38 38 and a half 38 my turn my
turn all right you look older like three
centuries
like he looks like he came from the
1700s and then dressed like he goes you
look over there
all right 30 30 what 30 41. you're like
the keanu reeves of our generation yeah
yeah all right well you don't care
though joe i don't [ __ ] care no just
tell me the number 45 45 let's go
all right all right like like
like 30 41. 30 41. 30 41. all right
anthony
[Laughter]
anthony is um that's all we got for the
video today guys
[Music]
you know what i love that he's really
thinking about it to give us a good
answer yeah i want to give you an
accurate answer he only gets my good
side but what's anthony though 30
30 30s late 30s
30s lately he looks older but you're
giving me the same age 38 37 37 are you
spelling out numbers
it's like he's saying a code or
something yeah because it's like usually
it's like
an
anaconda right there
[Laughter]
as accurate as the thing bart
i'm trying to be accurate i don't like
trying to say that i'm trying to i'm
trying to change the second note what's
the gauge like what are you analyzing
well
okay look well
he has a little fish here you know what
i mean a fish like a fish um
like a crow's crow's feet crow's feet
okay so that minus is maybe like six
months
he was really adding it i was trying to
add it i didn't know i was gonna [ __ ]
in this feel
like what the [ __ ]
dude
no but no but you have you have nice
skin i'm [ __ ] crowing now he's gonna
be all look like going like this i got
45 dude
he said you look older he gave me the
same age 45 is a joke that was a haha
wait i think you got everyone's age
right except for both yeah you did he's
still 15. hey i'm 17 years old dude
you're not even allowed to work here
wait right are you yeah yeah yeah you
got everybody's ready
what was yours 39. i just turned 39 yeah
yeah that was his birthday
like a week ago see i would try to be
accurate that's really good yeah if i
[ __ ] said it
he's all hella right like what the hell
right yeah man that's my time everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you